dr. Edward J earlier is a professor of
political science at California State
University San Bernardino he is a senior
fellow of the clairement Institute in
addition to being a member of its board
of directors from 1988 to 2006 doctor
earlier was a member of the California
Advisory Commission on civil rights and
in 1996 he served on the California
constitutional revision Commission he
has tested testified before the House
and the Senate Judiciary Committee's on
birthright citizenship voting rights and
other civil rights issues he has
published numerous articles and law
reviews and professional journals
including Marbury V Madison and the
progressive transformation of judicial
power and he has also contributed to the
encyclopedia of the American
Constitution he is the author of the
American polity essays on the theory and
practice of constitutional government as
well as the co-author of the founders on
citizen and immigration so at this time
it is my distinct honor to introduce dr.
Jay I'm sorry dr. Edward J earlier dr.
thank you for saying those nice things
it's good to be back in Hillsdale again
and to see so many good friends in the
audience and indeed to be in front of a
friendly audience I'm not always in the
presence of such a friendly audience you
can imagine many times scholars of my
ilk to say conservative or should I say
right-thinking scholars are not treated
as Hillsdale audiences are want to treat
scholars with understanding and indeed
sometimes compassion well our topic
tonight is the Supreme Court and civil
rights where are we and where are we
tending first of all what do we mean by
civil rights generally when we speak of
civil rights we refer to those rights
that are associated with the Equal
Protection Clause of the Fourteenth
Amendment we could speak of civil rights
as being those rights that are
associated with the privileges and
immunities of citizenship or perhaps
even those rights that are comprehended
in the bill of rights in the
Constitution but I think that I will
limit myself here this evening to
speaking about equal protection rights
now an important case will be heard by
the Supreme Court very shortly in just a
few weeks involving a race conscious
affirmative action program at the
University of Texas this case is Fisher
versus Texas and it will decide whether
a
racial classification intended to
promote student diversity at the
University whether those classifications
are consistent with the Equal Protection
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment now
this question had already or has already
been decided in the case of Gruder
versus Bollinger decided in 2003 when
the court approved a race-conscious
admissions program at the University of
Michigan law school but I think the
situation at the University of Texas is
sufficiently different that the Supreme
Court may want to reconsider that 2003
decision another case that the Supreme
Court will have to take up in the near
future I think involves what appears to
be an unresolvable conflict in the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 as originally passed
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 prohibited
employment discrimination against any
individual on the basis of race
ethnicity or sex a later amendment the
Civil Rights Act of nineteen ninety-one
added a disparate impact provision which
allows a claim of discrimination to be
established on the basis of
disproportionate racial results the
impossible situation here is that to
avoid a disparate impact violation
employers might feel themselves obliged
to engage in racial discrimination
against individuals in order to achieve
acceptable racial class results now in
Ricci versus DeStefano which was decided
in 2009 the Supreme Court ruled that a
municipality could not discriminate
against
individuals on the basis of race in
order to insulated itself against the
claim of disparate impact the city of
New Haven Connecticut held competitive
examinations for promotions within its
fire department even though the test had
been professionally designed to
eliminate racial and ethnic bias all who
scored high enough for promotion were
white or Hispanic in order to avoid a
disparate impact charge that surely
would be brought by black firefighters
the city discarded the exam results and
decided not to promote anyone this
decision of course disappointed the
settled expectations of those
firefighters who had passed the exam and
they claimed disparate treatment under
the Civil Rights Act they alleged their
civil rights had been violated by a
decision was made solely on the basis of
race the court in the ricci decision
attempted to avoid the intractable
contradiction in the law by arguing that
the city of New Haven had no strong
basis in evidence that it would have
lost a disparate impact challenge and
therefore it's discrimination against
the individuals who passed the exam
violated the prohibition against
disparate racial treatment the court
however gave no credence no credence
whatsoever to the argument that the
Equal Protection guarantees of the Act
were at war with the disparate impact
provisions now the idea between the
display I dia behind the disparate
impact provisions added in 1991 was that
equality or equal opportunity can be
measured only by equal results whenever
a policy does not produce equal results
there is a prison
option of racial discrimination a
pervasive argument that was used during
the debate over the Civil Rights Act of
1990 one was that many employment
practices that appear to be
non-discriminatory actually perpetuate
subtle forms of racial discrimination
much was heard in the federal
bureaucracy and the Congress about the
goal of equal opportunity being merely a
subterfuge for perpetuating the
lingering effects of past discrimination
in fact President Lyndon Johnson had set
the stage for this racial class
understanding of civil rights in his
speech that he gave at Howard University
in 1965 freedom is not enough the
president said the next and the more
profound stage of the battle for civil
rights is not just equality as a right
and a theory but equality as a fact and
equality as a result to this end equal
equal opportunity is essential but not
enough the sweep of Johnson's
pronouncement was almost breathtaking
freedom is not enough freedom is not
enough because although it protects
equality of rights it may not produce
equality of results there is no doubt
that the principle of distributive
justice embodied in the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 was equal opportunity but if
equal opportunity is not enough then
some form of unequal opportunity will be
necessary to achieve equality of result
thus restrictions on the freedom of some
would be the necessary condition for the
Advancement of others those who be
came to be known in the firm ative
action parlance as specially protected
classes or preferred classes and it is
precisely in this sense that the Supreme
Court ruled in 1980 that in federal
affirmative action programs using racial
set aside quotas as a remedy to cure the
effects of prior discrimination a
sharing of the burden by innocent
parties is not in impermissible those
who did not contribute to the injury
must therefore be made to pay the price
of the remedy that from the Supreme
Court in 1980 now after many years of
indecision in the 1980s the Supreme
Court began to reject the idea that
equal protection rights were conditioned
by racial class considerations and
finally in 1995 the 1980 decision
approving racial set asides that
trammeled the rights of non-minorities
was overruled a majority of the court
now seems to accept the idea that equal
protection rights belong to individuals
not to racial groups or other kinds of
groups that equal protection rights are
not conditioned by racial or ethnic
class considerations now I consider this
development a sign of progress at a
source of considerable optimism for the
future and this from someone who rarely
ever expresses optimism
now Justice Scalia in his concurring
opinion in the Ricci case lamented the
fact that the majority opinion did not
reach the constitutional question but
rather rested its holding exclusively on
statutory grounds Scalia argued that the
majority decision and here I'm quoting
merrily postpones the evil day on which
the court will have to confront the
question of whether the disparate impact
provisions of the Civil Rights Act are
consistent with the Constitution's
guarantee of equal protection now it is
unclear at least to me why Scalia said
that this would be an evil day perhaps
this was only his famous sarcasm at work
or perhaps he fears a bad result in any
case everyone concede that Justice
Kennedy writing for the majority in
Ricci failed to resolve the massive
contradiction that remains at the heart
of the Civil Rights Act the Civil Rights
Act continues to measure the civil
rights of individuals by the racial
class concept embodied in the idea of
disparate impact even though the results
of the decision in Ricci was the
protection of the legal rights of the
individual plaintiffs the time should
have been right for the vindication of
their constitutional rights under the
Fourteenth Amendment now if you'll allow
me to make a digression here I think it
will make what I say later somewhat more
palatable even if you don't allow me to
make a digression here
you have nothing to say in the matter
and he'll do so anyway I want to speak a
little here about James Madison and the
founders may give us a little insight
into what the idea of equal protection
of the laws means from the beginning so
James Madison frequently remarked that
all just and free government results
from social compact indeed this is the
basis of government in the declaration
of independence the declaration
specifies that the just powers of
government derived from the consent of
the governed because all men are created
equal because that is no one by nature
has the right to rule anyone else the
only legitimate source of rule is the
consent of those who are to be ruled and
the only legitimate reason for consent
is for the safety and happiness of those
who agree to be ruled in a growth in
agreeing to join civil society each
individual freely accepts the obligation
to protect the rights of fellow citizens
in return for the protection of his own
rights the just powers of government are
thus directed to the equal protection of
the equal rights of those who consent to
be governed equal rights life liberty
pursuit of happiness derived from the
laws of nature and nature's got equal
protection of those rights is the very
definition of the rule of law equal
protection of the laws is thus intrinsic
to the social compact and it is
therefore intrinsic to the Constitution
itself the Constitution notes that we
the people do ordain and establish this
constitution it's important to note that
it is the people who established the
the Constitution does not create the
people the people create the
Constitution the people were created by
the Declaration of Independence here's
something important the people are
excuse me the Declaration mentions the
people both in their political capacity
they are called one people and in their
moral capacity they are called a good
people once the people is established
Madison says that a second contract is
necessary this time between the people
in its political capacity and the
government this contract to carrie's
reciprocal rights and obligations the
people consent to be governed under the
forms of the Constitution and those who
occupy the constitutional ocupas of
government for their part pledged to use
the constitutional powers of government
exclusively to promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to the people however whenever
the government evinces a settle design
to disfranchise the people of their
rights the people always reserve the
right to alter or abolish the government
in order to secure new forms that are
better calculated to promote their
safety and happiness this is what has
come to be known as the right of
revolution a necessary add attribute of
the people's sovereignty which serves as
the ultimate guarantee of every other
right this right to alter or abolish
government is the only obligation that
is mentioned in the Declaration of
Independence and it is the only
obligation mentioned in the Declaration
because it is the ultimate expression
of the people's sovereignty it is the
ultimate ground of all obligation now
the Constitution was intended by the
framers to pit the principles of the
Declaration into practice to set those
principles into motion but as as in all
things political it is never possible to
translate theory directly into practice
insofar as the Constitution allowed the
continued existence of slavery it was
only an incomplete expression of the
declarations principles Madison argued
that the compromises with slavery were
necessary to secure the adoption of the
Constitution otherwise the slaveholding
States would have bolted the
Constitutional Convention and as the
most thoughtful of the Federalists
understood without a strong national
government the prospects of ever ending
slavery of ever bringing the
Constitution into harmony with the
principles of the Declaration were
remote that's the Prudential compromises
in the Constitution designed to protect
slavery were actually in the service of
eventual emancipation adoption of the
Declaration made the abolition of
slavery a moral imperative Chief Justice
tani in the Dred Scott case a decision
that was handed down in 1857 denied that
the Declaration carried any such moral
obligation or any such moral imperative
in fact he infamously denied that blacks
of African descent were included in the
phrase all men are created equal his
proof the founders did not abolish
slavery all at once abolition would have
been there
our moral imperative had they actually
believed what they said tani of course
missed the important ingredient of
democratic statesmanship that guided the
framers now in his response to Dred
Scott Abraham Lincoln insisted that the
authors of the Declaration included all
men but they did not declare all men
equal in all respects they defined with
this tolerable distinctness Lincoln said
in what respects they did consider all
men created equal equal in certain
inalienable rights among which are life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness but
the Declaration did not mean to assert
Lincoln insisted the obvious untruth
that all men were actually enjoying that
equality nor Lincoln stated did the
framers have the power to equalize
everyone all at once the statement that
all men are created equal was not of no
practical value in winning the
Revolutionary War and it was not put in
the Declaration for that purpose rather
was intended to set up a standard Maxim
amoral in political guide for the future
an attempt to declare the declare the
right Lincoln said so the so that the
enforcement of it might follow as fast
as circumstances should permit it would
be a standard Maxim familiar to all and
reverb but revered by all constantly
look to constantly labored for it and
even though never perfectly attained
constantly approximated and thereby
constantly spreading and deepening its
influence and augmenting the happiness
and and value of life to all people of
all colors everywhere the principle of
constitutional statesmanship advocated
here by Lincoln one that he learned
from the founders was this eliminate as
much evil as possible while possible
without destroying the basis for the
elimination of further evil this was a
statesmanship that was utterly alien to
Chief Justice tani and it was Tiny's
singular lack of understanding that was
the proximate cause of the Civil War the
American Founding was not completed
until the Civil War had been won and the
Reconstruction Amendments had been
adopted and those were the Thirteenth
Amendment which abolished slavery the
14th which established the citizenship
of the newly freed slaves and extended
to them the whole panoply of civil
rights that are the necessary incidents
of federal citizenship and the Fifteenth
Amendment which secured the right to
vote the framers of the Reconstruction
Amendments frequently referred to the
Declaration of Independence as the
organic law of the nation and their
constant theme was the necessity of
completing the founding here's only one
example from many our fathers had been
compelled to postpone the principles of
their great Declaration and wait for
their full establishment till a more
propitious time that time ought to be
present now that said in 1866 debate
over the 14th amendment speaking of the
Fourteenth Amendments Equal Protection
Clause 1 Clause one of its principal
architects noted that this is balash
assal class legislation and does away
with the injustice of subjecting one
cast of persons to a code not applicable
to another it protects the black man and
his fundamental rights as a citizen with
the same shield which it throws over the
white man without this principle of
equal justice to all men and
equal protection under the shield of the
law there is no republican government
and none that is really worth having
similar sentiments were frequently
expressed in the debates over the civil
rights act of 1866 an act that was being
considered at the same time the 14th
amendment was being debated the civil
rights act was entitled an act to
protect all persons in the united states
and their civil rights and furnished the
means of their vindication this act
protected the rights of citizens of
every race and color to make contracts
the own and convey real and personal
property and generally to full an equal
benefit of all laws and proceedings for
the security of their person and
property leading members of the third
the 39th Congress moved to put these
guarantees in the Constitution as an
amendment that would be beyond the reach
of future congressional majorities and
the civil rights act of 1866 eventually
became the basis for the Fourteenth
Amendment which was ratified in 1868
there is no doubt in my mind that a
majority of the members of the 39th
Congress certainly a majority of the
Republican leadership understood equal
protection rights in the 14th amendment
as an expression of the principles of
the Declaration of Independence which in
constitutional terms met the equal
protection of equal rights now after
this digression I think we are better
prepared to address the questions
involved in the Texas affirmative action
case consider this an amicus brief has
been filed before the Supreme Court by
several prominent law / 4th professors
supporting the university's
race-conscious affirmative action
admissions program
this ameet amicus brief argues that the
framers of the 14th amendment
contemplated the use of race conscious
laws designed to benefit racial classes
specifically the law professors point to
the Freedmen's Bureau bill passed in
1865 and re-passed in 1866 since these
bills were debated and passed in near
proximity to the debates over the
Fourteenth Amendment the law professors
insist that they shed reflected light on
what the framers met by equal protection
of the laws the law professors make a
simple equation since the freedmen
Freeman's bill embraces race conscious
action this must be true of the
Fourteenth Amendment as well now the
Freedmen's bill was indeed directed at
providing protection for the rights of
the newly emancipated slaves protecting
them from continued violence and
preventing their reinstatement under a
system of indenture or peonage but a
quick glance of the legislative history
of the Freedmen's bill demonstrates
conclusively beyond cavil that the law
professors has simply misrepresented
legislative history to justify racial
classifications the full title of the
Freedmen's bill is an act to establish a
bureau for the relief of freedmen and
refugees its principal sponsor explained
the bill this way it would provide for
refugees and freedmen refugees of all
colors as well as friedman in order that
all shall have temporary relief the
relief he said extends alike to blacks
and whites and to all colors the
Freedmen's bill was a warm a
a war powers measure to design to
protect all refugees Friedman as well as
white loyalists now the distinguished
law professors here stretch credulity
beyond limits when they present the
Friedman's bill as evidence that the
Fourteenth Amendment allows
race-conscious laws I believe that this
is ideological scholarship at its worst
a scholarship that frantically and no
doubt dishonestly strives to place
racial consciousness at the center of
equal protection analysis had these
professors been bolder they might have
claimed that the 13th amendment which
abolished slavery was affirmative action
program in 1997 the texas legislature in
1997 the texas legislature passed the
law ordering the University of Texas to
admit the top 10% of high school
graduates this admissions policy was
admittedly designed to increase the
number of underrepresented minorities at
the University but it attempted to do so
in a racially neutral manner and while
the policy did achieve a measure of
success and increasing the number of
minorities enrolled at the university
administrators were concerned that
minorities chose a limited range of
majors so that while the university as a
whole exhibited racial and ethnic
diversity it was not true of every major
and every classroom the University
reported that ninety percent of the
participatory size classes their quote
contained less than a critical mass of
underrepresented minority students
participatory size classes were those
enrolling five to twenty four students
these made up a majority of the
undergraduate classes and it was
precisely these classes that provided
what university administrators said was
the best opportunity for robust
classroom discussions and the rich soil
for diverse interactions and according
to the University it was in precisely
these classes that minority students
reported feeling isolated and that a
minority a majority of all students felt
there was insufficient minority
representation in these classrooms for
the full benefit of diversity to occur
the university thus concluded that a
race conscious policy was necessary to
ensure that diversity would be
represented in all the university's
programs and in a greater number of
classrooms and not just in those that
minorities were apt to choose for
themselves now the Fifth Circuit Court
of Appeals in a decision handed down in
January two thousand eleven frame the
constitutional issue this way and I'm
sorry to read this rather complicated
and abstruse sentence but I really have
no choice while the university has
combined its explicit use of race to the
elements of a program approved by the
Supreme Court and Gruder versus
Bollinger the program acts upon a
university applicant pool shaped by a
legislative legislatively mandated
parallel diversity initiative that
guarantees admission to Texas students
in the top 10% of their high school
class the ever-increasing number of
minorities gaining admission under this
top ten percent law casts a shadow on
the horizon to the otherwise plain
legality of the Gruder like admission
program it's hard to read that even
I think everyone can see that this is an
unnecessarily complicated way of saying
that the fact that the university has
increased diversity by non-racial means
calls into question the
constitutionality of its attempt to
accomplish the same goal by race race
conscious means in other words if they
can do the same thing without racial
classifications why do they need
race-conscious classifications the
circuit court nevertheless upheld the
race conscious plan believing apparently
that the special freedoms accorded to
the University by the first and
Fourteenth Amendments required the court
to defer to the expertise of the
administrators now the fact that the
Texas University of Texas has achieved
significant diversity through non-racial
means may compel the supreme court the
united states supreme court to
reconsider its decision in Gruder versus
Bollinger you remember this is where the
Supreme Court approved they race
conscious policy for the University of
Michigan Law School another development
that may favor reconsideration is the
fact that justice O'Connor the author of
the majority opinion in the Gruder case
has since been replaced by Justice Alito
who does not seem to have the same
squeamishness about upholding equal
protection rights now in the Gruder case
justice O'Connor argued that the
university had unique First Amendment
rights and those rights gave the
university great freedom to determine
for itself the best methods of providing
effective education the law school
diversity policy the court agreed
promotes cross racial understanding
helps to break down racial stereotypes
and provokes livelier more spirited and
more enlightening and more interesting
classroom discussion and the court
concluded if it was the considered
opinion of the University faculty and
administrators that racial and ethnic
diversities serve these essential
educational purposes then the court
would defer to the judgment of these
experts what was odd here was that when
the court is faced usually when the
court is faced with racial
classifications it rarely if ever defers
to the good faith representation of the
state actors who insists that racial
classifications are necessary rather the
court automatically applies what it
calls strict scrutiny strict scrutiny
presumes that racial classifications are
unconstitutional unless the state can
show they serve a compelling government
interest in there are narrowly tailored
to serve that interest in other words
the court always presumes that racial
classifications are in the service of
invidious purposes strict scrutiny
analysis simply indulges the AA priori
assumption that the arbitrariness of
racial classifications can play no
legitimate role in the rule of law so it
is surprising not to say unprecedented
to see the court here casually relying
on the good faith representations of the
law school administrators that law
racial and ethnic classifications are
necessary to serve a compelling interest
good faith representations have never
been deemed adequate to justify racial
classifications another surprising
element of Justice O'Connor's opinion
was her uncritical acceptance of the
distinction between a racial quota and a
critical mass the court seems to have
agreed over the years that policies
meant to fulfill racial or at
quotas are patently unconstitutional
racial and ethnic balancing for its own
sake clearly violates the principle that
equal protection light rights belong to
individuals not groups in Gruder however
the law school insisted that its
emissions policy did not mandate quotas
but sought to assemble a critical mass
of underrepresented student minorities
not a specific number or percentage but
a meaningful number or meaningful
representation or a number that
encourages underrepresented minority
students to participate in the classroom
and not feel isolated the law school
administrators did indicate however that
they kept a daily tally of the number of
underrepresented minorities that were
admitted to ensure that the critical
mass goals were being met as Chief
Justice Rehnquist pointed out in his
dissent however a critical mass sounded
suspiciously like a quota especially
since the numbers that satisfied the
requirements of a critical mass were
virtually the same as those that we
constitute a racial or ethnic quota the
Chief Justice even had the ill grace to
call the critical mass objectives of the
admissions program a sham the Supreme
Court of course used to it here
scrupulously to the proposition that the
Constitution prohibited simple-minded as
well as sophisticated forms of
discrimination and of course the
critical mass scheme employed by the law
school was far from sophisticated but
given assurances of good faith by
administrators justice O'Connor and a
majority of the court were willing to
defer to representations that strained
the limits of credulity not to say the
limits of imagination never in the
history of strict scrutiny analysis have
transparent claims to good faith served
as the justification for racial
classifications now Justice Thomas in
the Gruder case wrote a powerful dissent
in which he concluded that whatever
marginal improvements that might be
produced by the law schools racial
tinkering he said cannot justify racial
discrimination and certainly cannot
survive strict scrutiny analysis
furthermore just as Justice Thomas
argued the court's reliance on social
science evidence that racial
experimentation leads to educational
benefits might have serious collateral
consequences he cites a growing body of
social science evidence that purports to
show and here in quoting racial and
other sorts of heterogeneity
heterogeneity actually impairs learning
among black students other studies he
cites indicate that african-american
students at historically black colleges
experienced superior cognitive
development and higher achievement than
those attending predominantly white
colleges hmmm Thomas asks whether the
court would defer to the expertise of
the administrators of an historically
back black college if using this social
science evidence they wanted to
establish a race-conscious admissions
program to promote racial homogeneity
what would the quartic would the court
except the representation of these
administrators as readily as they did
those in the Gruder case if not how
would they distinguish the cases now
justice Thomas's solution is as simple
as it is elegant the principles of the
Constitution should not be subject to
the fatties trends of social science the
Constitution Justice Thomas rightly
contends abhors classifications based
upon race
not only because those classifications
can harm favored races or are based on
illegitimate motives but also because
every time the government places
citizens on racial registers and makes
race relevant to the provision of
burdens or benefits it demeans us all
for the immediate future thomas
concludes the majority has placed its
imprimatur on a practice that can only
weaken the principle of equality
embodied in the Declaration of
Independence and the Equal Protection
Clause its Justice Thomas well
understands the idea of man as it
appears in the Declaration has no color
the proposition that all men are created
equal expresses what is essential in the
principles of human nature race
expresses only what is accidental and
contingent curiously enough the courts
failure to deal with the issue of racial
classifications can be traced to Brown
versus Board of Education famous case
decided in 1954 we don't criticize Brown
versus Board because of its result
segregated schools did violate the Equal
Protection Clause of the Fourteenth
Amendment but we criticized it for its
reasoning its failure to declare that
the Constitution was colorblind you
remember that in 1896 the Supreme Court
had rendered its infamous separate but
equal decision in Plessy versus Ferguson
as long as the races were treated
equally the court said segregation did
not offend the Equal Protection Clause
of the Fourteenth Amendment because a
mere separation of the races did not
imply a
edge of inferiority Justice John
Marshall Harlan in a lone dissent wrote
that are caught our Constitution is
colorblind and neither knows nor
tolerates classes among citizens justice
Harlan would have disallowed racial
segregation as a matter of
constitutional law in the brown case
however Chief Justice Warren was
disinclined to rely on the Constitution
saying we cannot turn the clock back to
1868 when the 14th amendment was adopted
here was his reasoning its most avid
proponent Warren stated undoubtedly
intended to remove all legal
distinctions among citizens okay let me
repeat that it's most avid proponent the
Fourteenth Amendment its most avid
proponents wish to remove all legal
distinctions among citizens but he says
its opponents were antagonistic to both
the letter and spirit of the amendment
and wish the most limited effect what
others in Congress and the state
legislators had in mind cannot be
determined with any degree of certainty
now I'm wondering here is why do the
opponents of the amendment figure into
this calculus did not lose and didn't
the proponents of the amendments when
Warren uses this as an argument as to
why we can't determine what the
Constitution means we have the proponent
but we have the opponents therefore we
don't we can't rely on the Constitution
because we can't determine what it means
well I'm not a scholar of logic but this
seems to me to be rather illogical in
warrens irrefragable if I can call it
that logic the fact that the opponents
had another vision seems to cast doubt
on
any attempt to rely on the Constitution
rather Warren decided that a more
reliable basis for a decision was modern
social science yeah whereas plus he had
concluded that separate is not
inherently unequal by 1954 Experimental
Psychology had indicated that at least
in the context of grammar school
education a separation of the races
creates a feeling of inferiority that
may affect the hearts and minds of
school children in a way unlikely to be
undone and here's what Warren said
whatever may have been the extent of
psychological knowledge at the time of
Plessy this finding is amply supported
by modern Authority so the difference
between the holding in brown and plus E
was not one of constitutional
construction but developed developments
in the science of psychology under the
tutelage of Chief Justice Warren modern
psychology had replaced the Constitution
for purposes of equal protection
analysis the result in brown was that
only those racial classification that
creates feelings of inferiority are
prescribed by the Constitution this of
course left open the question whether
racial classifications that are designed
to benefit rather than harm a racial
class violate the Equal Protection
Clause the so-called benign racial
classifications that have no invidious
purposes but are limited exclusively to
benign purposes we've been struggling
with that issue ever since nearly twenty
years ago again I'll quote here from
Justice Thomas Justice Thomas expressed
the view that I believe in
is essential to a proper understanding
of equal protection jurisprudence this
is an opinion that was utterly shocking
to liberal constitutionalists who
continue to insist that racial
consciousness must remain at the core of
equal protection analysis here's what
Justice Thomas said I believe there is a
moral and constitutional equivalence
between laws designed to subjugate a
race and those that distribute benefits
on the basis of race in order to foster
some current notion of equality
government cannot make us equal it can
only recognize respect and protect us as
equal before the law I think the supreme
court only needs to take one sort step
to do the job that Brown versus Board
failed to do it should declare that the
Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment commands a
colorblind Constitution which need
neither knows nor tolerates classes
among citizens Fisher v Texas should be
the case where the supreme court
completes the job some years ago Justice
Kennedy and he may provide a key vote in
the Fisher case wrote that the moral
imperative of racial neutrality is the
driving force of the Equal Protection
Clause and I might add that it is the
moral imperative of the Equal Protection
Clause because it is the moral
imperative of the Declaration of
Independence thank you for listening
I think so because of overalls Gruder
will say no racial classification no
race consciousness in university
admissions and so far as I can tell the
only racial classifications are
so-called benign classifications that
survive today are those in universe
university admissions policies because
here the court has said that the First
Amendment gives the university's a
special place academic freedom that
comes from the Bakke case and that's
what the Gruder case relied upon so I
don't know one interesting thing is that
when it comes to racial classifications
for a long time the court was toying
with the idea that if it were benign
racial classification then strict
scrutiny analysis didn't apply but then
they got over that in 1995 and the court
said no know if there's a racial
classification we apply strict scrutiny
and there has to be a well-defined
injury and so on and so forth and they
begin to hate hedge in the area go ahead
and ask your next question yeah sure you
say that academia is the only place
where racial classifications are
prevalent but did the New Haven
firefighters case comprise exactly that
in his new Kagan on the court now well
the Gruder case was a Fourteenth
Amendment Equal Protection our First
Amendment Fourteenth Amendment case but
the rekey case was a statutory case not
what I I predicted that there has to be
another Ricky case and that will be a
constitutional decision now what I'm
hoping there is that the court will come
from
confront directly two incompatible parts
of the Civil Rights Act the disparate
impact provision and the the disparate
what they call the disparate treatment
provision they are incompatible they're
at war with no now that you can't
measure individual civil rights by a
racial proportionality requirement so
there I think as Justice Scalia say we
have to make that decision I don't know
why he called that an evil day when the
decision will be made I thought when it
came to that kind of sarcasm or cynicism
I was the champ but he's much better at
it than I am so did I answer your
question I'm not okay we have a question
down here why not recognize the problem
of the civil rights and civil liberties
being in conflict the courts often refer
to freedom of association and if you
assume that means Congress shall make no
law with respect to associations you
should be up the people involved in the
moral values to decide with whom to
associate free of government
interference well I think as a general
matter that's the case we there's
nothing we do have the right of freedom
of association but we have I think a
legitimate place for non-discrimination
laws in public places and those kinds of
things sure but individuals have a right
to to associate with whomever they
please but in public places I think it's
a different matter there can be
legitimate laws forbidding racial
discrimination in a variety of places I
have no problem with that and I think
it's legitimate yeah
going back to brown did Thurgood
Marshall argue a colorblind Constitution
or did he argue the social science track
no he argued a colorblind Constitution
he's actually a pretty eloquent argument
that he made before the court he says we
we've been praying for the day when the
Constitution would be colorblind and so
on and so forth he was a little
embarrassed by that argument in later
years when he began to argue that the
civil rights act was merely a an
elaborate racial class remedy for racial
class injuries in silence fought forth
but he did argue very strongly for a
color black Constitution when before the
court yeah unfortunately this will be
our last question in a country where
some are trying to write here yeah I'm
sorry in a country where some are trying
to racial eyes the issue of immigration
what do you think will be the judicial
fate if any of things like the DREAM Act
who's trying to racial eyes immigration
you mean in our country yes I am unaware
that people are racialized in it I mean
I understand that most of the people
coming to the country illegally are from
Latin American countries and if but I
don't think that that in and of itself
is racial icing that the immigration
issue or do you think it is in what
sensor is that racial izing the issue
could you give him back the when I've
heard people say that it's a racial
issue because we're not so worried about
the Canadian sir
but I don't think that that's the point
that's that's actually much of what I
mean if someone has misgivings about
illegal immigration for instance it's
often you know they're often painted to
have well I'm a co-author of a book that
strongly argues against illegal
immigration because i think that one
aspect of sovereignty a nation's
sovereignty is be able to determine who
become citizens and who never do a
irreducible aspect of nations
sovereignty is to be able to determine
who gets to come to the country and who
could who can become a citizen of the
country and so on and so forth but I
don't think that we've ever had in the
old days a part of progressivism was to
inject racial race into immigration
policies and the progressives in the
early part of the century believe that
we should only allow superior races to
immigrate to the country they thought
they knew who the superior races were
but we've gotten over that a long time
ago and I don't think anybody's
advocating that anymore but I do think
that we that no country is sovereign
that can't control its immigration
policies and I I simply don't believe
that there's any racialism involved in
this at least I don't see it but I could
be wrong about that thank you dr. alario